I'm unwilling to become pregnant
if I don't have unrestricted access to healthcare
and that includes abortion rights
and if any part of you is thinking they won't
I live in a blue state I live in Minnesota
they won't enact a national abortion ban
they've literally been planning this for 50 years
they haven't denied it
they have both indicated that they would like to enact a national abortion ban
Vance tried to reframe it the other night by saying well
it's not really a national abortion ban
I'm just an advocate for national minimum standards
that's the exact same thing as an abortion ban
saying that throughout the country
you can't get an abortion past six weeks
15 weeks whatever arbitrary number they come up with
maternal mortality rate in Texas alone has jumped 56%
one part of it is obviously fear right
I don't wanna become pregnant and need emergency healthcare
and not be able to receive it and
or die but another part of it is like
if what my government sees me is as a reproductive vessel who doesn't have um
her own free will control over her body
know what she needs have her own destiny that is valued
then I don't wanna give you what you
I'm not gonna do that I really don't wanna do reproductive labor for you